the biggest Boon for skateboarding was
because of Tony Hawk's video games yeah
that was a huge one for all those in the
19 like 97. that was uh later 2000 when
did the first one the on Playstation
come out that was like 98
I don't know I mean Tony Hawk did the
900 famously in 1999. and I think that
that made like oh that that created
it was because
uh my character after they did it came
in on pro skater 2.
and like they were already it was
booming that that's already it was that
super lucrative for you what do you mean
that having your character character in
the video people still talk about it
right but but did they pay you a bunch
of money
uh I remembered like I had a character
in Tony Hawk's Underground two like it
was like an uh secret character that you
had to like find and unlock and then
you'd be Stevo riding around on a
mechanical bull through the game and uh
like to have my character I got paid
five thousand bucks like that I think I
got it yeah I think I got the exact same
thing but you're saying like on the
first one like those people that made
the characters are like
all the main characters like Alyssa
Steamer Bam Bam Kareem Muska Rodney all
those guys life-changing funny that yeah
that was what do you mean like like over
Mill
I I think so I I think so they may have
gotten royalties
yeah I think there's life-changing money
I think they got royalties and for all
of the
um like piracy and [ __ ] in the world
like you know like goddamn video games
you pay 60 bucks for the disc
that costs two bucks to make I mean it's
the biggest
it's the biggest [ __ ] profit margin
ever yeah in the world and I don't I
somehow think that you couldn't like uh
pirate them I think that clip was
awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what I've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first books Five star rated
on Amazon and I have no doubt this one
will be too so get the autograph copy
right now at stevo.com
yeah dude